we've seen new data which shows the
scale of ethnic minority under
representation in local government it's
the first ever complete census of
councilors and it found just seven
percent of them are from a black Asian
or minority ethnic background when in
fact they make up 14% of the population
as a whole
researchers at the University of
Manchester log the percentage of people
from an ethnic minority on each council
and this map shows exactly what they
found as you can see metropolitan or
City Council's shown here in yellow are
home to some of the UK's largest pame
populations like London and Manchester
and they're more likely to be diverse
but even many of these under represent
the communities who live there for
example only 13% of Westminster
councillors are from Abbey AME
background compared to 38% of the
population
Brighton & Hove has a disparity of 11
percentage points as does quite
surprisingly Manchester there are places
where be AME people are over-represented
such as Hounslow but this is rare and
that's played a key role in
long-standing inequalities this is a
wake-up call for party leaders to say in
their localities what is the plan to
ensure that you have a membership that
looks like the people you're seeking to
serve what is the plan to ensure that
talent goes from A to B to high office
you know too often political parties
across in the fingers and hoping that
people will come forward and that they
will have a representative Parliament
it's not good enough you need to have a
comprehensive plan to recruit retain and
promote talent and once you have that
you have a representative local
authority that can serve the needs of a
diverse community the report also looks
at how many councillors from an ethnic
minority background are women it found
just 3 in 10 Asian councillors were
female and black women made up the
majority of councillors 6 out of 10 from
that community in 2019 more ethnic
minority MPs were elected to Parliament
than ever before but this progress has
masked the reality of representing
at lower levels of government finding
out why this is an issue is crucial as
councils are where power is closest to
the people and at a time of heightened
discussions around institutional racism
and inequality the lack of ethnic
representation can reinforce that
disadvantage and tackling it could
bridge the long-standing diversity gap